elections are only days away in Nigeria
the presidency and seats in Parliament
are being contested
but critics say one group is having too
much influence on the votes State
Governors I think a lot of anger about
governance in Nigeria actually goes to
these Governors because the impunity of
these Governors they are misruled they
are bad governance is part of the pain
that Nigerians are going through
since Nigeria has returned to democracy
in 1999 State Governors have influenced
who becomes president
with full access to State funds and
resources they can choose candidates for
political office anybody aspiring to be
president of course he will have to take
Roots through the government because of
the connectivity of the governors and
the Grassroots
but critics and activists say such power
is harming democracy and governance in
Nigeria and they want it reduced
limiting their powers require amendment
to the Constitution and the electoral
law but with increasing number of
Governors getting elected into a
parliament that's supposed to make loose
changes Nigerians will have to wait
longer for that to happen
some are hoping these elections will
Mark a turnaround with a woman now the
front-runner for State Governor post a
big step in a male dominated Society
but until then literally expected to
change Party politics and governors in
Africa's most populous country
Idris Al Jazeera maiduguri